[Music]
and welcome back to another exciting
episode of careful boys oh hey be
careful stay careful boys and we got
welter here today
walter what's up man it was a walter
where is the where you from walter i'm
from fullerton
i think i haven't seen you in like three
years yeah right it's been a while but a
little backstory we've known walter now
for
definitely over seven years yeah yeah
for sure maybe like 10 years maybe yeah
i think maybe 10. how'd you guys mean
back in the day when we had this channel
called just kidding films we did
sketches and all this stuff and we were
like getting our foot in the door like
learning about entertainment in the
asian american entertainment circle yeah
and walter comes from a stand-up comedy
background
oh gee one of the first asian
entertainers
but i don't know how og how old is she
um i'd say second wave
who's the first one who's gonna be like
henry cho margaret cho uh who's henry
cho henry cho is a korean guy from
tennessee yes he's still talking
southern california he's still touring
he's not on tv is that first way like mr
miyagi oh okay if you want to go first
yeah actually
no because he was doing stand up before
he was mr miyagi
pat marina and uh johnny johnny yoon
from they call me bruce so that's they
were okay let's go first their first way
is it first wave the japanese dude that
saying the [ __ ] sukiyaki song that
went viral the first gangnam style oh
yeah probably
why does it have to be japanese what
like what kind of korean i just had i
don't know dude i had to bring it up i
had to [ __ ] fight for my peoples bro
so yeah let's go let's go johnny yoon
and uh pat maria's first wave and the
second wave would be like henry cho
margarcho
and then i'd say probably like two and a
half is bobby lee because he bobby lee
came in a little bit after henry
margaret and then i think like the third
wave would be like pk
uh me like danny cho dr ken dr ken all
those guys steve byrne
um kevin shay katie tatara kitty tatara
yeah and then now from what i understand
during coronavirus there's a lot of
asian comedians now they all suck though
isn't it i have no comments
no comment because i remember
there was a time in asian entertainment
like um we all freaking knew each other
yeah there was a there was a moment when
like there was new media and then there
was like the asian film festival group
that did all the traditional film and
then the stand-up comedians and then the
dancers yes right and then at that time
early two thousand ish that's kind of
when we met
or mid 2000 right and then that i think
everyone was like one degree apart now
if there's asians in entertainment
no we don't even know who they are no
you know and i think it stems from asian
the whole and i don't want to like paint
asians all in the same brush but like we
have our pride and we all want to be the
boss
whereas like you get other curiosities
yeah koreans basically
i didn't want to say koreans out loud
because then joe get all excited he's
like this is why we occupied your
country
we all want to be the boss you know and
so like other ethnicities gay people
they're fine working with under other
people and they thrive but like with
asians it's like oh they set up this
company i'm gonna set up my own rather
than working for somebody else i wanna
set up my own this is another jk i'm
gonna set up my own bro
so that's that's my own personal theory
i i could be wrong but i'm hardly ever
wrong so
out of the middlewave ones i like rodney
chain a lot oh yeah ronnie yes i don't
know when ronnie started because he
started in another country so we usually
don't count them
because he's from australia yeah as
asian americans he would be first wave
out there yeah he could have started
australia
we got beef there's beef the only
australians i like that are korean are
jenny and uh
such a small like
and they're in black pink shout out to
black people
i'll just see blink right here
yeah but we don't we don't count other
countries because it's different the
stand up is stemworld's different yeah
it's just america obviously is the
pinnacle of usually entertainment and
stand-up is a lot more difficult here
uh whereas other countries i'm not gonna
say it's easier but uh
for asians it's probably a little bit
what's more difficult here just
in anything because if i if i lived in
let's say hong kong
granted there's only like one or two
clubs
there's not that many there's not as
many comedians but here you have to deal
with everyone i mean there's thousands
of comedians just in la alone
and so um getting stage time is it's a
lot more what have you seen that's
changed over
have you been doing comedy for 20 years
professionally i want to say i'm bad
with time but professionally i want to
say a little under 10 years
professionally speaking yeah because you
used to host chocolate sundaes out
laughing i didn't host no i uh no i uh
became i was i'm a regular chocolate
sundae that's kind of like how i got my
start um is kind of getting on chocolate
sundaes
you're like the token asian guy among
the black guy
now i think there's a few but like back
then um were you the punching bag i
think you have to be
in the comedy world just cut throat off
because you know the way i mean the way
i am yeah i don't know the question is
that bro
you're a punching bag [ __ ] of the group
did you suck like this guy bro when i
was in the military i'm the only asian
guy out of 80 dudes right yeah so anyone
and everyone that had any even slight
funny thought i'm just the punching bag
for every single like asian thing that
they can think of just got bullied bro
that's just being bullied no they're
close it doesn't sound like me they're
brainstorming with me it doesn't sound
like he's bullied
[Laughter]
bart's going home he's like yo like i've
been coming up with jokes with my
platoon dude yeah they're all asian
jokes
they're all small dick jokes
they got this little bit called ching
chong i'm the star yeah they pull their
eyes back and everything is so fun they
had a quad ching
that's what they
this in the marines play and he's the
star
starring ching chong clon
for christmas they had me dressed up as
the japs this time
and they chased me around the basement
there's some [ __ ] war reenactments
it's 80 dudes fighting against one jab
he's like dude but there's diversity i
get to play the chinese guy the japanese
guy the korean guy the vietnamese guy
it's awesome well it's like next year i
get to be genghis khan
but no no they didn't they didn't do
that to me
i don't know
i assume a room full of comments you're
just [ __ ] around all day for black
comics you know they would say stuff
about liquor stores and stuff and like
you know like you know why you guys
always follow us around like because you
guys never buy anything
you gotta clap back you're like stop
having your cousin steal stuff
it's simple like
that's you know i i always hit back i'm
sure stereotypically yellow people don't
hit back yeah um because we're you know
culturally we're not brought up that way
yeah but like i hit back but comedy is a
different game you have to yeah well
well it depends on the style comedy
because that's why i actually like
walter and then we're just like do we
got to bring them on jk we got to do
sketch sketches with them because we
actually saw one of your shows i don't
know where i think it was um when pk did
the the asian night the life factory
right yeah and then you stood out
like amongst all the other asian comics
because i grew up in my uh favorite
comics were actually black stand-up
comics like i didn't really get white
humor and all that and that's probably
why my humor was more like urban and
stuff we have a joke yeah he's a black
comic
inside he's a black comedy his jokes his
sensibility all my favorite stand-up
comedians 70s though
yeah he's pacing up and down the stage
teddy murphy yeah dude like i i studied
richard pryor like all that and then so
like
your style was more like oh dude you
remind me of like the asian guys that i
grew up around it's like we grew up
around like black mexican and this is
our humor and all the other asian
stand-ups i didn't relate with them
because i'm like yeah
i don't know it's a different kind of
comedy i don't i don't know what you
guys are talking about and then so i
think like with me and bart too we're
like oh we got to bring walter on
because it's different right like you
represented that kind of asian versus
especially from back then too like
you're already like a strong presence
yeah and hitting back from back then so
that was really cool why'd you ask him
if he was the punching bag
well you don't have to it's not a bad
thing
i don't know
depending on who you ask
he's a punching bag that punches back
dude
i said punching back
back
oh man how has comedy changed on the
last 10 15 years
you know yes people are more sensitive
now oh and i was gonna ask that like how
do how does that work because i hear
from so many standups
that like it's it's more of a difficult
space like people quit going to
universities and doing shows there and
even for us too like um we had to change
our style yeah yeah it's like okay let's
go for boys now yeah they're pretty yeah
yeah be careful like i someone tried to
cancel me
but what's funny is like i'm nowhere big
enough to be cancelled so
i think it fell on deaf ears cancel you
in real life can't just tell me [ __ ] up
well no no um so they i i would have um
so i did a joke um well it didn't start
out this way but like the host i didn't
know ethnicity she was uh it was like it
was an asian show and so i was like are
you are you chinese are you like
southeast asian or what and she didn't
really respond so i was just like oh
look
let's just start talking about southeast
asian women like vietnamese women like
they always want to upgrade so they want
to get one of the main the big three
which is chinese japanese koreans
[Laughter]
how do you feel about this i also want
one of the big threes
well you ended up getting with an aussie
yeah
is that a downgrade i don't know it's
down under yeah see there it is bro
another one
let me clean this guy dude i can still
dream today's video is brought to you by
feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as stress
anxiety pain and all this crazy stuff
it's like do you ever wonder
what would you do when you're freaking
out because you were out snowboarding
all day because you know snowboarding
season is right now and you guys are out
on the slopes and you're like oh my god
i'm so excited i need to go to sleep so
i could snowboard again tomorrow what do
you do me thanks to spiels i get a
couple of uh
droplets it comes in a cool little
packet right there and you go to put it
on my tongue and then i have a nighttime
routine so for me i have a difficult
time turning that off but with the help
of feels i get it right under my tongue
and i start my unwinding technique so i
could get a full night's rest and go out
it again and what's really cool about
them is if you got stress anxiety or
sleepinesses you want to try fields but
you're like oh my god this is my first
time i never did this before they have a
cbd hotline that you can call and
they'll walk you through the whole
process so you feel extremely secure and
safe you could be like hey i'm trying to
snowboard but i can't go to sleep
because i'm so excited what do i do
should i jack off yeah i take some
fields
feels to feels good and the best part of
all is there's no hangover or addiction
to this people might have this
misconception but that's not the case
it's just something to help chill you
out and what's cool is they even have a
monthly membership so that you can make
self-care really easy it's just going to
show up at your doorstep and you save
money on every order so if you want to
feel better you got a little bit stress
anxiety make sure you become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's feels f
e a l s dot com slash o f f t h e r e c
o r d
off the record go to feels.com off the
record to get 50
off your first order plus free shipping
and so you know clearly i'm a comic and
but i think what's and she's a comic too
right everyone's [ __ ] around yeah but
i think someone heard the bit or like
someone heard what saw the show or
whatever because it was an online show
and uh they got upset about it and
hey look if you're getting upset that's
fine but i think people have to
understand that i'm a comic i'm not a
politician
and uh it's all under the umbrella of
being a joke now whether i'm serious or
not which of course i was but
but under under the umbrella of comedy
like power how are you gonna take one
specific thing and go with that because
i'll give what the what happened was the
comic after uh her bit was her mom told
her don't date korean men and don't date
um vietnamese men don't date cream men
because they'll beat you
and don't date vietnamese men because
they steal
if you want to compare which is more
racist
mine was positive
you can get out of your situation and
upgrade that's a positive hopeful thing
hers was flat out korean men will beat
you and vietnamese men will steal what's
the upside to that joke and so the
person that was trying to cancel me
didn't say boo about the comic after wow
and then to um further because they're
probably southeast asian and they feel
like something about that statement yeah
they're like that's true
well the thing is i think yeah this
person's vietnamese and was we're not
lower people we're not looking and then
she was okay with her her guys saying
you know being told that they steal
because
but then like two comics before the guy
was talking about how asian men have
small penises and i thought let's take
that for example and say hey why are you
perpetuating that that negative
stereotype
even if it's true why perpetuate it and
it's an old joke dude
you gotta yeah
you gotta evolve it about one
if you're gonna complain about one
you've gotta complain about it all yeah
and so i think to me what's highly
unfair with the council culture is
people cherry-picking what fits their
own narrative yeah yeah that for me is
highly it's what they get offended about
yeah it's what hurts them right exactly
which chapel with the with the trans
community trying to cancel him
um fine if you want to be offended by it
you want to cancel them okay i respect
your opinion and you can do that however
you're going to have to go after
chappelle for all the other racist jokes
that he does because if you don't go
after all of them then if you're
laughing at the other ones exactly
you're guilty too yeah so you can't
single out just because it affects you
yeah like i was at a show one night
where all the comics made fun of every
race out there and then the last comic
had jokes about gay people two gay guys
got up and walked out so they were
laughing through the whole show
the whole show and they got to live and
i thought that's not that's not fair but
they're they already pay for their two
drink minimum they pay for everything
yeah then that's okay
as long as you pay
to get out then get out it's technically
fair they just had to go yeah they had
to go we'll try to beat the parking yeah
last comic all right
it's kind of like um victor it's like
playing victim but you're actually
bullying right because that means that
you'll laugh at someone being bullied
because it's funny but then when it
turns around and you feel bullied you
throw a fit yeah yeah and then because
it's like you're going into a room where
there's jokes right it's a jokes like
court it's like watching a football game
on a football field everyone's tackling
or having a good time but when your
brother gets tackled all of a sudden
like beep no no no no no
exactly right like what the [ __ ] like
this is a game of football happening on
a football court and which is what
comedy is right
he's wearing pads that's what he gets
bro he's wearing pads he should have
been suited up like i'll take bart's
example even further it's like you go to
a football game and then a guy throws a
pass and they get mad why is he throwing
a pass what the [ __ ] kind of you're at a
football game
what do you think is going to happen of
course
it's like you're at a comedy club yeah
jokes are gonna happen like what do you
think was gonna happen when you walked
in
like we're not all gonna hold hands and
be like oh you're so beautiful
you're so pretty and handsome oh what do
you think is gonna happen it's like the
people that sit in the front row and
they're surprised that the comics make
fun of them yeah yeah yeah that's the
perfect roasting place people people sit
there on purpose because they want to
get that's like the shamu splash zone
that's what it is
i got wet sitting here locked up the
whale
i hate seaworld giant signs i said you
will get wet yeah
they're selling ponchos to you guys
what are those for why do we need them
do you think it's because now with the
internet and everything like there's so
much more access to comedy that like
before you had to walk into a club
before you had to like
like watch a special right and then like
people that really gravitated toward
stand-up comedy in the world just like
improv and everything
it was kind of niche it wasn't
mainstream entertainment right but now
comedy podcast all that it's so big
combined with
uh you know the sensitive pc culture i
think that like people don't understand
the game so like in your bit as comics
we know that that's not how you
really be like you're not you're not
there making a lecture you're there like
playing on stereotypes because that's
what comedy is a lot of the times like
if you if you could label it it's it's
kind of satirical it's also um
you're making fun of the belief that
some people have that east asians are
superior to south asians right so if you
break it down in a more academic way
you're making fun of that and then
it's funny because there are idiots out
there that believe that and you're
making that statement so it's like when
we do it's called um what it's it's it's
not irony it's called um there's another
word for it [ __ ] slipped my mind but
it's when you make fun of
the type of people that believe this and
then you embody that character like
satire it's kind of like satire it's
kind of
damn i'll i'll i'll probably think about
it way later but it's like and we did
that um it's like absurd comedy too
like we become characters that people
think asians are and then we make fun of
like what borat is yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think get mad at you
for portraying that but what borat does
is he exposes racism he makes fun of if
you're smart enough to see it exactly
but if you're dumb enough you'll just be
like why is borat making fun of jewish
people yeah you know what i mean so i'm
like dude that's where the space is i
think kind of weird is there's hell of
people that come in and they don't know
how to make sense of it it's weird that
people don't recognize there's a game
being played because it's like you don't
go to a
watch your favorite singer and when
she's singing about like a breakup song
and you're like wait but you're married
[Laughter]
she's playing the game of songwriting
right yeah of singing
you don't draw it to real life beyonce
you're not single you can't represent
single ladies you just like kiss jay-z
back there what the [ __ ] when i listen
to kanye west sometimes and he talks
about like [ __ ] other [ __ ] but i'm
like but you're married to kim and i
always think i always think i'm like i
wonder if they have conversations about
that yeah i wonder if kanye and kim like
if she gets mad at him like hey like
come on man that's not very very honest
i thought his whole last album was about
like god and his mom now he said
something about [ __ ] [ __ ] in there
you have to of course if it's hip-hop
it's a requirement they have a checklist
they have a checklist
it's a quota you know you gotta hit a
quota dang that's sick
i do feel this feeling though that like
canceled culture went so bad
that it went to the point where no one
gives a [ __ ] that much like people are
getting cancer and they're coming back
and then so people feel safer to just be
like oh it actually doesn't do anything
let's just talk and do what we want
comedians are really good at that yeah
they're coming back from cancellation
louis ck and and dave chappelle both got
like uh award nominations
uh and both of them quote-unquote have
been cancelled or whatever so it's kind
of like what what does it mean to be
canceled yeah and at that time we
thought louis ck was gonna be done
because it was like around the harvey
weinstein stuff and then he just used
that in his comedy and then that's the
one that's getting an award killed and
he killed it was so good that's crazy
and the way he handled it was so funny
too like oh yeah was something like that
strong of a subject matter at that time
where everybody was like because that
was probably one of the most popular
cases
in the beginning and then the fact that
he turned into a comedy special do you
believe in the ratio of as long as a
joke is funny enough then it's not it's
not like offensive well i think for each
community they have their own line of
what that is i don't do rape stuff i may
i mean discuss rape but like i don't
joke about rape
um that's just me oh you don't i mean
[Music]
oh that was my favorite genre
[Laughter]
man they advertised you wrong bro
it's a hard it's a hard line to walk
yeah yeah like there's certain things
that it's kind of difficult yeah
genre yeah
yeah so like when i go on stage you
should probably like just like noise
cancel headphones probably because
there's gonna be no rape jokes i i do i
do you know racist stuff uh but my
mind's more poking fun at the entire
thing of racism like how it just doesn't
it doesn't make sense you know um
but like yeah but i i fully admit when
i'm on stage like i'm racist
probably
probably
probably yeah
it's possible but you know it's funny
now because they do
um
distinguish racism and prejudice now the
line's a lot finer and thicker now than
it was before
racism it's about racism as an
institutional uh thing so like for
example like you guys are like let's say
let's take just kidding films for
example yeah and then um you guys just
you guys didn't do that let's say you
said no white people
that would be racist because it's
institutional but like if you as your
individual that's why we have a
diversity card of one white person
yeah we're diverse we're a diverse
country legal purposes yeah we keep them
on payroll yeah but like if now as an
individual bart and you said hey i don't
want to work with white people that's
prejudice and that's okay that would be
racism because you're not an institution
you're just speaking as bart so it's
gotta be like a company or a yeah
that's where they kind of differentiate
the two now right but i just say i'm
racist because i'm egotistical and i
consider myself an institution
that's right
walter hogg incorporated how you see
yourself yeah right he's a sole
proprietor dude so when i say i don't
work with white people i feel like
thousands of people be affected by that
yeah and they won't work with white
people either yeah um so yeah i just
fully readily admit that i am uh racist
that's pretty cool you man that's pretty
progressive of you yeah man i'm proud of
you bro you know
i'm here to help pay for the way
[Laughter]
where are those rape jokes huh
[Music]
you